Оце нам, щоб було тепло.
На жаль, тепер така погода,
що я просто не можу.
Ні розпалити кузню, нічого,
бо вітер віє сильний.
Це є бронза з домішками
олова, цинку, алюмінію трошки.
То є різні...
Дуже багато сплавів у латуні.
І вони, як у нас називають, — «мосяж».
Це так гуцули прозвали — «мосяж».
Латунь — то вона і є латунь.
Але мосяжництво просто
не дуже важке у плавці.
Легко різні фігури виплавляти.
От робите з глини форму,
яку хочете.
Розплавляєте метал,
заливаєте.
От така була пряжка,
відливалася.
Колись різні речі у побуті робили:
ключі робили, от що хто [робив].
Тут це випилювалося,
і до замка був ключ.
Це колись використовувалося в побуті,
не лише суто бартки [топірці].
Дідів ще прапрапрадід робив,
коли займався мосяжництвом,
ще за опришків.
Робив опришкам топірці,
і так це все пішло.
Потім вуйко робив,
і так вони навчилися.
І дід, і дідів брат також цього
навчилися і цим займалися.
І так це споконвіку пішло,
і я залишився в цих традиціях.
Я ніде не вчився.
Я просто виріс з дідусем.
Дідусь постійно працював, різні речі виробляв також:
для побуту, топірці і різні такі речі.
І я так поступово...
Все бачив, все вивчав,
щось пробував змалку.
І як підріс, то також
почав виготовляти топірці.
Топірці — бо через те, що в нас,
як-то кажуть у гуцулів,
без топірця не відбувалося нічого.
Ні весілля, ні батяри, ні опришки —
без топірця вони не були.
Колись з давен це в побуті
було постійно.
Як-то кажуть, сокири не було,
то коли люди виливали собі
«сталінки́», ходили з цим,
це було як підпора,
щоб прорубати чи в ліс піти,
чи куди би не було — це постійний був атрибут.
Усі карпатські регіони навколо, які....
Бартка використовувалась
переважно як палиця,
бо гірські люди без палиці
нікуди не йдуть.
Бо йти чи по скелях, чи по цьому...
Є пастухи, [які] відганяли
колись вовків чи якусь звірину.
Мали чим оборонятися.
Це було як знаряддя постійне в побуті.
Орнаменти переважно геометричні
в гуцульських топірцях.
Воно чогось так споконвіків,
що пішли такі трикутники, кола.
Кожен майстер собі
має свою роботу.
Наприклад, всі ці писаки,
це все я створюю сам.
Коли є час,
і щось спало на думку,
я сідаю і роблю якийсь писачок.
Є різні види, різні...
Є такі, є квіти,
є такі підковки.
Є така квітка.
Ну різні, що тільки захочеться.
Щось на кшталт сніжинки.
Таке, як сердечко.
Що прийде в голову,
щось пробую, виробляю.
А потім уже
використовую у чоканці.
Лише треба хотіти.
Це треба любити,
щоб навчитися.
Я з маленького вчуся
і досі ще вчуся.
Як-то кажуть:
«Вік живи — вік учись».
А просто так показати можна.
Але це треба вникнути душею,
аби це почати робити.
Бронза сама по собі червона.
А латунь уже жовта,
вона так під золото.
Якщо її добре відполірувати,
то вона дуже жовта,
схожа на золото.
Ну й довго вона зберігається.
І як файно покрити лаком,
відшліфувати,
воно довго стоїть,
не чорніє.
Бо мідь, наприклад,
окислюється дуже скоро.
А латунь не така.
Це є з орнаментом,
є, як-то кажуть,
з такою різьбою сухою,
просто відлитий
і відшліфований.
Є «чоканка» —
суто почоканені топірці,
які не мають ніякого кольору,
нічого, просто вирізьблені.
Як-то кажуть, різьба як по дереву,
так і по металу.
Треба його припасувати,
щоб він рівненько стояв.
Вже залишилося дуже мало мосяжників,
я один з останніх майже.
І не знати, чи хтось буде
продовжувати вже це ремесло.
Це лиш буде вже в підручниках,
або десь в історії, в інтернеті,
що були колись мосяжники.
Бо так до того йде,
що ніхто не хоче цим займатися.
Колись ходили з топірцями,
з трембітами, з рогами так, як і скрізь.
А зараз традиції щось покинули.
От Верховина, туди, там Криворівня,
вони дотримуються традицій.
Вони більшість...
Переважно на свята я маю
постійно там замовлення.
Бо йдуть нові люди в колядники.
У когось вже старий топірець,
хтось хоче нового, оновити.
І постійно я маю туди замовлення,
бо люди дотримуються традицій,
і я туди працюю.
♪ Всі полонини, широкі поля, ♪
♪ Широкі поля, синії моря, ♪
♪ Бо колідочка — це Божі слова, ♪
♪ Їх українська, рідная мова. ♪
От і все.
У дуже пришвидшеному темпі.
Я ще так ніколи не робив скоро.
[сміється]
Утворюються перемети.
Ми їдемо зараз,
наближаємося до Косова.
Після Косова будемо їхати
на нічний ринок.
Кутський ринок.
Базар нічний тому,
що, як-то кажуть,
всі сувенірні ярмарки, які проводяться,
переважно в вихідні дні.
Люди приїжджають торгувати
вдень на ярмарки.
Нічний базар,
бо вночі скупляться і поїдуть уже
на ярмарки, на якісь різні базарчики.
І навіть з-за кордону люди
приїжджають на ці ринки.
Це сувенірна продукція,
яка розходиться по всьому світу.
Одне-єдине, що нам може завадити,
що менше людей буде,
бо дуже сильний мороз.
І холодрига на цей момент.
А так люди їдуть,
дехто з того живе.
А дехто й цим живе тільки.
З нашого села багато їздять,
бо є багато майстрів по різних виробах.
Є інкрустація, якісь палиці, обереги —
ну дуже багато різного.
І ложки, лопатки,
і все [що завгодно].
Я вже 17 років їжджу на базар.
Щотижня я не їду,
але переважно, час від часу,
раз-два на місяць я їду.
Мене можна зустріти на базарі.
Сьогодні людей дуже мало.
Переважно тут усі продавці є,
а тепер нема.
Сьогодні мороз,
і люди на базар не вийшли,
не захотіли мерзнути.
Поки стоїмо,
так і мерзнемо.
Зараз, на цей час, уже дуже мало майстрів
залишилося по цій справі.
А я хочу продовжувати це,
бо це мені цікаве,
я люблю цю роботу.
Хоча би щоб не зникли традиції,
не зник сам процес мосяжництва.
Якщо ми не будемо знати минулого,
[якщо] не будемо зберігати традиції, історію —
у нас не буде майбутнього.
Україна для нас —
це найголовніше, що є.
Ми боролися за Україну ціле своє життя
і боремося по цей Божий день.
Ми пролили стільки крові за Україну,
що Україна — це найголовніше.
Україна для нас — це все.
Особливо для гуцулів.